mujer vida libertad
fue el eslogan escuchado este sábado en
Berlín al llamado de una asociación
feminista casi 80 mil personas de toda
Europa asistieron Para apoyar a las
mujeres iraníes
tengo un mensaje para todas las mujeres
todas somos hermanas con los hombres que
nos apoyan somos hermanas y hermanos
quiero que el pueblo iraní sea Libre
como todo el mundo
entre la multitud mujeres pero también
muchos hombres y un mensaje para los
políticos
es importante que los políticos europeos
comprendan que se trata de un momento
verdaderamente histórico se trata de un
proceso revolucionario Así que no
estamos seguros de cuánto tiempo llevará
pero la dirección está muy clara
en Tokio la marcha fue organizada por
las vías para iraní algunos sostenían
retratos de víctimas de las protestas de
Teherán
en Suecia cientos de personas se
reunieron para protestar contra el líder
de la revolución iraní con cánticos
hostiles
[Música]
al mismo tiempo en Irán se están
produciendo nuevas manifestaciones como
aquí en una universidad de Teherán un
movimiento de protesta que lleva más de
un mes desencadenado por la muerte de
maxa amini el 16 de septiembre tres días
después de su detención por la policía
de la moral